first story from
americanmary video Texas prepared for
standoff with Biden 10 States send
troops and law enforcement to the Border
Governor Abbott told former Fox News
host Tucker cosson Friday that 10 states
have already sent National Guard troops
or other law enforcement members to the
southern border to Aid Texas in the face
of growing pressure from President Joe
Biden's Administration to allow border
patrol agents to remove razor wire
barriers the state installed to deter
illegal immigrants from pouring into the
state during Friday's interview with
Carlson Abbott said he would be
surprised if any of the 25 Republican
states that have pledged to support his
state did not send additional assistance
quote there have been about 10 states so
far that have sent National Guard or
other law enforcement Abbot said they
are now joined together with us and this
is a fight for the future of America now
I don't know what's currently going on
news is happening very uh it's changing
rapidly with what's happening on the
border today was the deadline the bid
Administration was supposed to do
something apparently I've seen some
people uh spreading a rumor that there
was some uh they said okay today's the
deadline but then they said something
like 6 p.m. and I have not heard
anything just yet some people are saying
there's very little information coming
out because something is actually going
on behind the scenes but I don't know
for sure part of me wants to believe
because of normaly and optimism bias
this will all blow over but considering
Ben Shapiro is the number one rapper in
the world I think it's more likely to
just erupt in the most absurd way
imaginable I think it's important to
point out that at one time Democrats
spoke like Donald Trump did about
illegal immigration and about the
borders um people like uh Chuck Schumer
uh people like Harry Reid after the
first bombing of the World Trade Center
he even Harry Reid even talked about how
the 14th Amendment is interpreted to
confer citizenship to an illegal alien
uh who has a baby on American soil he
thought that was wrong they even use the
term illegal alien people like that said
this kind of stuff Amy kichar said it
Diane Feinstein said it now all of a
sudden they've done a 180 and anybody
who feels the way Donald Trump feels is
a bigot
no it's crazy I I think our uh country
forgets that at one point we were
willing to talk openly about the ills of
illegal immigration as a country became
afraid of being called racist and then
we said it's okay we'll just leave the
Border open and now everyone else pays
the the the cost of it both financially
and psychologically it really detracts
from the American Spirit if we have a
class of people in this country who are
not actually a part of it and we say to
the legal immigrants the things that you
did to get here the sacrifices you made
were actually for nothing because you
don't get the benefits of cross Le that
people are concerned about being called
racist and more that the Democrats
realize this is a big voting
constituency uh and they wanted to
change the electorate because they were
losing elections uh America was a 50-50
Nation but you bring in a bunch of
people who are going to pull the lever
for the Democratic party they assume and
all of a sudden you you're guaranteed a
governing Coalition for Democrats in in
the future that's why they're doing this
yeah it's it's pull the Lev or just
change the Census Data but it's it's it
gives them congressional seats and
electoral votes of course the argument
that that that you hear them make to the
average person that's say like low
politically low political information is
that the you mean stupid people I'm
trying to be nice
um is that our our uh unfunded
liabilities are going to destroy the
economy and we need to have people come
in to work because we do not have
replacement uh levels of of having
babies and
stuff and I think that there is some
some validity to the argument which is
why I think it's convincing I think that
that gets to I think that that makes
makes enough of an argument to convince
people that are again that are low
information what do you think is the
best way to convince them because I talk
to people that just they'll see stuff AR
the argument have validity that U
population getting older unfunded
pension liabilities so-called
entitlements so we need to bring in new
people in order to make them contribute
so that these people get their full
benefits it has still has to be legal we
have know who they
are what they're here for what their
intentions are you just can't come
across the border and go okay well
you're you're solving our unfill
unfunded pension liability problem it's
ridiculous and and I I got to say before
I would ever accept that proposed
solution I would accept if you have
three babies you pay zero federal taxes
I'd love it yeah my my my only point or
the only point in asking that question
and the thing that I'm concerned with is
convincing people that the situation is
untenable convincing them that this is
actually a problem because I do believe
that most people don't pay attention you
know most people don't really watch the
news very closely and then when they do
they tend to listen to what the the
Talking Heads say and they assume that
that's the truth Michael mice talks
about you know when you tell the average
person that the news is lying to them
they what it's like you're you're being
told that the the meteorologist is lying
to you and he knows right most people
think the news is telling the truth how
and my concern is convincing them that
we actually do have a real problem and
so I want to know what what people think
the best way to you know to actually to
move the needle because the this is it's
coming to a head where we're where it's
possible that we could meme ourselves
into actual conflict like everything is
theater until someone actually does
something and anytime you get dudes with
guns in close proximity with opposing
interests there's a chance for that and
I don't want to see that happen well
Phil let's talk about the sin here the
original sin is Joe Biden he comes in
and he literally says essentially the
borders are open during the debate
against uh uh Donald Trump he said
there's going to be a surge to the
Border he promptly reverses every single
one of the Trump policies they gave us
the most secure Border in our history
and I know that it is I'm staying in a
hotel where you guys send me there a
whole bunch of DEA guys there a border
patrol guys there and I had conversation
with one right before I got into the car
to come over yeah at at the hotel I stay
at where where you send me yeah I and
they had a whole bunch of uh border
patrol people staying there and I talked
to them told them where I was going they
knew who you were and um I said Donald
Trump often says that when he was
President we had the most secure Border
in our history is that true and there
were two guys there they said absolutely
it was true and they said it was like a
a switch was turned on when Joe Biden
came in he stopped the stay in Mexico
program he resumed catch and release uh
the Mexicans took off the 25,000 people
they had in their military move them
elsewhere uh and uh uh the the problem
then exploded he said overnight there
was a illegal alien coming across the
border being interviewed by a woman
named Martha radit she's a longtime
reported with ABC News and he and she
said to him if Donald Trump had gotten
reelected would you be here he said no
and she was shocked and he said why and
he said Joe Biden has given us permisso
change the rhetoric change the policies
and that's why they're here so that's
the original sin and so Joe Biden should
have seen this coming you think
America's going to sit around and watch
millions of people coming across the
country and do nothing about it are you
are you serious and the reason why
basically ask for it the reason they're
coming to Eagle Pass is because of the
controversy because you have uh if they
go to other places I think lukeville is
in Arizona they're uh places where
there's large there's a lot of
controversy you have leftist
organizations they know are prepared to
accept you and fight on your behalf to
enter whereas if they go to some random
you know open border like I could say
unprotected border area private property
otherwise they could get shot mhm you go
to Eagle Pass let the right and the left
fight about it and the border patrol
agents bring you in bring you to where
you need to go where someone gives you
money uh but I'll say I don't I don't
have a particularly high opinion of
border patrol agents right now however
should that report be be correct from I
from Colin rug that the border of Patrol
Union announced support for Texas then
I'm then I'm on board but CBP agents
have to stop facilitating the human
smuggling the I see a video of them
raising the razor wire to assist human
Smugglers those guys have committed a
crime they're just following orders
they're just following orders oh all the
more reason they should be in prison
they're just following orders they don't
want to do this they want to keep their
jobs they're just following orders and
and Phil to your point they should be in
prison to your point uh it is becoming
an issue uh in Iowa it's the number one
issue it's not even a border state I've
been traveling all throughout Iowa they
weren't talking about this when I was
there it's now become the number one
issue over U over over inflation over
the economy in in Iowa and the most
ingenious thing that the uh Southern
Governors did was start sending these
people to cities like Chicago uh in New
York and Martha's Vineyard because then
it came to them and all of a sudden now
they're taking this problem seriously or
more seriously than
before I have a friend uh good friend of
mine that was uh talking he's got a
friend that actually works at border
patrol and he isn't even like he's not
even convinced that they're like I said
he's not even convinced there's a
problem he's like well my friend says
that if they're here illegally that they
can that Texas can just put them over
the border and and he says so they're
the this is actually a show from uh you
know from DeSantis and a show from
Abbott and I'm like I'm pretty sure that
these people are coming and asking for
Asylum and that's why and that's the
problem and they're being processed in
and they let them in they give you a
court date 3 four years down the road
they don't show up in fact I asked one
of the guys today we have 8 million
illegal aliens in the country since uh
Joe Biden he said that number is
probably accurate I said how many of
them are going to be deported if and
when Donald Trump comes back he said I
don't see how we can possibly Rite him
up and get him out they're here for good
I'm pretty sure uh we we dealt with this
when um what was the who was the head of
ice a few years back Tom H hman right uh
I'm pretty sure in his testimony
outright said it it doesn't matter if
they're seeking Asylum Crossing through
Asylum legally you must go to a legal
Port of Entry and make a declaration
that means the CBP agents who there's a
video of them opening a gate in the
Ballard fence and and waving them in and
these aren't the only instances again
they were just folling orders so Tim
which is an excellent reason why they I
hold them 10 times more responsible than
I would if they were actually you know
uh uh the you're saying they're
intentionally committing felonies
because they were told to does not
change the fact they committed felonies
well that's fair argument but uh Joe
Biden uh and and mayorcas are telling
you with a straight face the borders are
secured no no Biden said the border is
not secure he said he said it recently
but before before before that when myor
said the borders are secured he doesn't
know the press secretary confirmed that
that she thought the borders were
secured I think uh I completely agree uh
uh Joe Biden should be impeached over
this and convicted over this talk about
Insurrection I oh I mean yeah subverting
the law violation of article uh I mean
uh Greg Abbott says article 4 section 4
and Article 1 Section 10 and so now he's
actively trying to stop the state from
defending itself yeah I think uh for
this Biden should be impeached and
convicted and following his impeachment
and conviction criminally charged along
with people in his administration that
being said the challenge we face right
now is the political barrier of we don't
want the Democrats to be able to sub out
Joe Biden at a time when Joe Biden is
like we want the people to vote to bring
in Donald Trump to solve the problem we
actually impeach and convict Joe Biden
they could bring in Michelle Obama or or
Gavin Nome and it's going to benefit
them thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at
timcast.net thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time